>> WHO IS IN CHARGE ON AMERICA'S
FOREIGN POLICY.
CHINA RAMPING UP PRESSURE AFTER
THE CONTROVERSIAL VISIT TO
TAIWAN BY NANCY PELOSI.
BEIJING SUSPENDING CERTAIN
ASPECTS, SENDING THE TAIWAN AIR
FORCE SCRAMBLING, DOZENS OF
WARSHIPS CLOSED IN.
NOW THE CRITICS SAY THAT BIDEN
IS LOOKING WEEK FOR POSTPONING A
FEDERAL MISSILE TEST IN THE
SOUTH CHINA SEA.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO RACKET
DOWN THE TENSIONS, BUT NANCY
PELOSI IS PUTTING HER FOOT DOWN.
>> OUR FRIENDSHIP WITH TAIWAN IS
A STRONG ONE.
IT IS BIPARTISAN IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT FOR PEACE AND THE STATUS
QUO IN TAIWAN.
>> ANTHONY BLANKET IS SOUNDING
THE ALARM OVER CHINA'S
ESCALATION.
>> THESE PROVOCATIVE ACTIONS ARE
A SIGNIFICANT EXHALATION.
THE SPEAKERS VISIT, THERE IS NO
JUSTIFICATION.
THIS WOULD BE ESCALATORY
MILITARY RESPONSE.
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT GOES
ON IN THE WORLD, WE'VE GOT THE
TALENT MAN, THERE IS A WAR IN
UKRAINE, RUSSIA IS STARTING TO
JOIN WITH CHINA ON VARIOUS
ISSUES AND NANCY PELOSI IS THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND SO WHY
THEY DIDN'T IS.
BUT NOW WE HAVE CHINA WITH
RUSSIA AT A TIME WHEN NANCY IS
DOING THIS, MAYBE SHE KNOWS
THAT.
AND I MEAN, WHAT IS SHE IN
TAIWAN FOR?
JUST TO CONTINUE WITH THE
POLICY?
I THINK IT'S A DANGEROUS TIME TO
BE DOING THIS.
>> SHE IS PUTTING HER FOOT DOWN.
AND ALSO THEY WONDER WHO IS IN
CHARGE WHO IS THE AGENDA OF THE
LEADER OF THE PARTY AND JOE
BIDEN IS BEING LED BY MORE OF
THE PROGRESSIVES IN HIS PARTY,
SOME HAVE SAID THAT HE IS
SURROUNDED BY THOSE THAT DON'T
HOLD THOSE VIEWS AND ARE
INFLUENCING HIM.
WHEN WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER.
SO WHO IS RUNNING OUR COUNTRY,
WHO IS CALLING THE SHOTS, BUT
WHAT IS HE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN HE DOESN'T STOP NANCY
PELOSI.
AND YOU HAVE SEEN IT ON TV AND
ITS CHINA'S CLAIM OVER TAIWAN,
WE HAVE A GOVERNMENT THAT TRIES
TO PACIFY AND KICK THIS DOWN THE
ROAD, IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AT
SOME POINT.
AND OF CHINA FEELS DESPERATE
ENOUGH TO SHOW THEIR POWER TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT NOW, I FEEL
LIKE THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND
WHEN IT HAPPENS AND IT IS AN
ISSUE.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD
BE INVOLVED IN THESE AFFAIRS,
BUT TRY TO SET A DELEGATION AS
WELL.
>> GETTING LETTING THEM GET AWAY
WITH COVID-19.
>> SHE DOESN'T TAKE HER MARGINAL
ORDERS FROM JOE BIDEN.
THE FACT IS THAT THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND THEY ARE GOING
TO SHOOT IT DOWN NOT TO STAND
WITH THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> IT IS PROBABLY WHAT IS OUR
BIGGEST ENEMY.
AND THE PRESIDENT HAD ZERO
RESPONSE TO IT.
AND HE HAD ZERO RESPONSE TO IT.
>> AS WAS SUGGESTED HOW SHOULD
HE BE RESPONDED.
>> HE SHOULD BE STATING THAT HE
WILL NOT WHATEVER WE HAVE TO AND
HE DID HAVE THAT LITTLE GAP
SAYING THAT WE WOULD INTERVENE.
>> WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT DOING WHAT LEGISLATORS HAVE
DONE BEFORE AND IN SUPPORT OF
HER, THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GETS INVOLVED IN
HER PLANS AND POTENTIALLY LEAKS
THE DETAILS INTO THIS, REGULARLY
POPPING UP BECAUSE SECURITY
MATTERS.
, LET ALONE SOMEWHERE LIKE
TAIWAN.
>> SENATOR COLLINS SAID IT WAS
THE JOE BIDEN A ADMINISTRATION
THAT HAD CONFIRMED.
AND THIS IS NO REASON FOR US TO
TURN OUR BACKS IN SUPPORT OF
TAIWAN WERE OF NANCY PELOSI WHO
IS AN INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUAL IN
OUR GOVERNMENT AND HOW MUCH IT
MEANS TO THE TAIWANESE PEOPLE.
THIS KIND OF SUPPORT MATTERS.
>> I THINK HER MESSAGING WAS
PERFECT, I THINK THAT IT WAS FAR
FROM PERFECT.
>> THE SPEAKER NEEDS TO CALL OUT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, I THINK.
HER LIFE IS ON THE LINE.
WHEN WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
THAT.
AS WE STARTED OFF ABOUT THE
PARTISAN POLICIES.
THEY THREATENED MY LIFE, WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT IT.
>> SENDING HIS REPRESENTATIVES